simplified 3x squared minus 8x plus 7
plus 2x to the third
minus x squared plus 8x
minus 3. so when they simplify this
we're essentially just going to add up
like terms and just as a reminder we can
only add or subtract like terms or
simplify like terms and just a reminder
what i mean by that if i add an x
squared to an x squared these are like
terms they're both x terms raised to the
same power the same degree so if i have
1x squared and then i have another x
squared well then i have 2x squareds
this is 2x squared if i have an x to the
third let's have 3x to the thirds
plus another 4x to the thirds well that
means i have 7x to the thirds
seven x to the thirds i can't take an x
squared and add it to an x to the third
i cannot simplify this in any way so
this you cannot simplify
cannot simplify these are not like terms
just because they both have x's the x's
are not two
they are not to the same degree so with
that in mind let's look at the x's that
are the same degree let's start with the
highest degree so the highest degree or
the highest exponent on an x here is
actually this x to the third here but it
looks like the only one it's the only
place where we're raising x to the third
power so that can't be merged or added
to or subtracted
to anything else so let's just write
that down so we have the 2 x to the
third and then let's look at the x
squared terms we have 3x squared turn we
have 3x squared over there and then we
have a minus
we have a or we could view as a negative
x squared over there so if we want to
simplify it we can add these two terms
we can add we can add let me just write
it down so we can add 3x squared to
negative x squared so i've just i'm just
rearranging it really right now but i'm
putting the like terms next to each
other so it'll be easy to simplify now
let's worry about just the x to the
first terms or just the x term so you
have a negative 8 x term right over here
so let me write over here negative 8 x
and then you have a positive 8 x term
right over here so let me write that
down so positive 8x
and then finally let's look at the
constant terms you could view those as
times x to the 0th power and the
constant terms are you have a positive 7
over here so plus 7
and then you have a negative 3 over here
you have a negative 3. so all i've done
is i've really just used the commutative
property of addition to just to change
the order or addition and subtraction to
change the order at which i'm doing this
but i've just rearranged the thing so
that the like terms are next to each
other but now we can simplify so we have
2x to the third nothing to simplify that
with
but then if we subtract
if we have let me do that in that same
blue color
if we have 3x squared and from that
we're taking away an x squared well
we're only going to have 2x squared left
so that's going to be plus 2x squared
and then over here if we have negative
eight x's and then we add eight x's to
it or you could actually swap these
around and you could view it as you are
subtracting you are subtracting 8x from
positive 8x well that's just going to
cancel out so that's just going to be
zero i could write a plus zero here but
that'd just be redundant wouldn't change
the value and then finally i have a plus
seven minus three well that is just
clearly seven minus three is four so i
have plus four and we're done we've
simplified it 2x to the third plus 2x
squared plus 4.